in an attempt to finally get rid of  scp-682 the hard to destroy reptile the  scp foundation considered leaving it  inside scp-3008  the infinite ikea and just letting it be  their problem for a change how do you  think it worked out the foundation  sealed 682 into a box and sent it inside  of 3008 with an unmanned drone there was  no response for 24 hours at which point  18 instances of the malformed ikea staff  exited the building each one carrying a  large box stamped with an ikea logo they  set these on the ground and then headed  back inside inside each of these boxes  was a living part of scp-682  and like all things that come out of an  ikea box 682 had trouble correctly  putting itself back together thankfully  this granted the foundation time to  re-establish containment before scp-682  had the chance to properly regenerate